good morning my name is Tim and I dated
one of the data scientists at statzig
I'm here to share what we've learned
from leading tech companies on how to
scale experimentation I'll sort of
discuss what the best practices that
they use which I believe are going to be
applicable for anyone doing
experimentation and how like a building
a good experimentation platform truly
democratizes data at your company
and with the sugar on top of all of this
is that once you're in the
experimentation space this actually
accelerates the pace of innovation at
your company
but let me digress a little bit and talk
a little bit about statsig and who we
are
statsig essentially we are a product
observability company what that means is
we provide our customers who are product
teams with the same analytically aware
engineering tools that power many of the
large tech companies you know the
products we are known for today are
feature flags and experimentation and I
think like underneath the hood what
makes them special is that these are
tools that not only democratize data
because data is a team sport but these
are tightly integrated into engineering
workflows and I'll talk a little bit
more about that
um but you'll notice that like these
tools change the way a company works so
this has meant that we aren't just
selling tools we're actually in the
business of selling culture
um some key facts we are based in
Bellevue and we're founded only in 20
just in 2021 so we're two years old
um and it was founded by a team of
ex-facebook product builders that
believe very much in the data-driven
product development
um philosophy uh we have grown really
fast uh we're already serving uh
hundreds of customers across thousands
of experiments and billions of users and
some of our more notable fast growing
startup customers include the previous
presenter whatnot but also companies
like headspace ancestry as well
I want to go over
um just a brief overview of like product
analytics because that's actually like
my history and my background but also
like the bread and butter of
part of like why we're all here the
foundation of this pyramid really is
like user analytics this is the widest
and also the deepest part of product
analytics it can it starts really with
being able to Define your kpis and being
able to just measure and track them but
it goes way deeper than that it can get
into like understanding funnels
understanding user conversion rates
doing things like building LTV models
understanding drivers of retention like
these are all wonderful and great
methods that are all well known but
however the real power to me or the best
tool in the product analytics toolbox is
experimentation
now while and the reason why is that
most tools in the product analytics
toolbox are correlation based but
experimentation is the gold standard for
causality the what the form of
experimentation that most folks will
know is the domain of website
optimization this is where you are
largely focused on optimizing tactical
metrics such as this is the classic red
button versus blue button I need to
drive click-through rates or I need to
increase sign up registration flows I
want to have a and this is largely a
domain of marketing teams
where we sort of differentiate ourselves
is we are in the field of product
experimentation and the reason why
product experimentation is a little
different is that products and users and
the way users interact with products is
complicated uh very um you need to be
able to understand the holistic impact
of your change you'll need to be able to
understand how that change affects your
users day over day how what your users
might be doing a week later if you are
Netflix and you're introducing gaming as
a product how does that affect your
video how does that affect people's
usage on your movies and shows how does
that affect their renewal rates like
these are things that are actually
fairly deep and cannot be boiled down to
a single metric
but even within this uh field there is
actually a group of companies that have
taken this to the next level and they're
doing what I would call ubiquitous
experimentation
these are companies that
um ah okay these are companies that
where the focus really is on the number
of experiments they launch and I'll
quote a famous inventor Jeff Bezos who
said that if you double the number of
experiments you do in a year you're
going to double your inventiveness
um that is those are words that we
believe to be very true
I'll drill in a little bit more about
like what these big tech companies are
doing they're doing something called
modern experimentation culture because
when you're doing experimentation on
this sort of scale it fundamentally
changes the way your company operates uh
everyone knows what experimentation is
so I will Define modern and culture
modern it's modern because products are
complex we are not just looking at
click-through rates anymore we believe
experimentation cannot be boiled down to
a single metric and that you must have a
holistic understanding of the
experimental effect this involves
understanding multiple metrics this
involves understanding trade-offs and
synergies uh this under this involves
understanding whether the effects you're
seeing are novelty effects or that these
are going to be durable for the long
term
um generally speaking you want deeper
more meaningful metrics ah
no I was on the right side you want
deeper more meaningful metrics uh and
you and you ideally business metrics
when possible
um but in terms of culture this is the
part to me where it gets things get
really special this is all about
experimental velocity and pace of
innovation for these companies
um this in this sort of world
experimentation is a team sport it's
done by not just data scientists it's
done by engineers and PMs data is
democratized
um but not only that data in order to do
this data has to be pragmatic
experimentation has to be pragmatic
that's why the integration into
engineering tools is really critical and
experimentation at this scale though
as I've mentioned changes your culture
your teams become metrics driven
information is shared data is King and
opinions become far less important
I like the slide a lot it's borrowed
from one of our PMS but when we when we
talk to people who are looking at
building an experimentation platform or
looking to upgrade their platform most
people focus on the stats engine these
questions look like are using Bayesian
or frequentis do you support the man
Whitney U test how do you handle peaking
how do you handle multiple comparisons
these are very important questions but
we have come to learn that this actually
misses the mark on what causes
experimentation programs to fail
experimentation really is about your
speed of innovation your ability to test
ideas quickly and get results if your
company is stuck in the like having
meetings talking about the proper design
and setup of your experiment if running
computations is a manual effort and
takes a lot of effort and resources from
data scientists to try all sorts of
fancy stats methods and if it takes your
team a long time to understand whether
you're making the right decision or not
experimentation has now become your
bottleneck whereas the number of ideas
your testing should be
and so one of the Hallmarks of these
companies who are in the modern
experimentation culture is that they are
they test almost everything
I'll share a little bit of a story from
my time when I was a data scientist at
Facebook I had an engineer come up to me
he made a one-line code fit codefix and
it was very obvious that code fixed that
there was an explicit typo and he
corrected the typo and he asked me
should I set up this as an experiment
and part of me was like not really like
this is clearly gonna work but I said
like you know what at Facebook the cost
of setting up an experiment is near zero
it's trivial and so I said like let's
just run this for two days and see what
happens we ran it the code worked it
fixed the bug but what was very clear in
the results was it introduced another
bug Downstream of that effect and so
like these sort of things are where like
experimentation actually reveals things
that you would not have necessarily
anticipated is like really important but
that only happens when you can drive the
cost of experimentation down to near
zero where it becomes automatic and part
of the Engineering Process
now I'll focus on experimentation best
practices there are a lot of blogs that
have been published there are even
really good books on experimentation in
the industry but a lot of the Practical
aspects are sort of like locked up along
these like top engine top companies so
we do a lot of time and effort speaking
with these experimentation thought
leaders and experts and practitioners
and there are a few common themes that
we have come to number one like you've
got to make testing easy you've got to
make it a simple to set up the
experiment and you've got to make
interpreting the results almost as
simple as monitoring a dashboard
you need to make experimentation
self-service and democratize and mention
that it should be accessible to not just
data scientists it should be PMs and
Engineers as well
um it's also really important to have a
standardized methodology so really
really good defaults really good
um Sops and this what this does is that
if every team is not handcrafting their
own experimental analyzes now results
are suddenly comparable across the
company when a different team is talking
about their results you know what they
did on Revenue you know that's
comparable to another teams because
they're using the same source of Truth
the same statistical methods they're
using consistent reproducible and
reliable methods not handcrafted
um I'll talk about a couple of the myths
that we have come across that are very
common one is overlapping experiments
companies tend to be very worried of
when you're running multiple experiments
now how do those experiments interact
and this is highly this sort of
interaction effect is actually highly
overrated for one in our my experience
like these things are fairly rare and
when they do occur they're actually
directionally consistent so but
unfortunately the real Sinister part of
this is that run is that when you keep
experiments apart from each other you
actually crushes your experimental power
the number of users you can put in
um and then which kills your
experimental velocity the second myth is
you don't need millions of users I know
we read about experimentation from these
companies like Facebook who have like
millions of users of throat experiments
you don't uh from what we have learned
what the same tools can be used at
experimentation from thousands to ten
thousands of users and I have a blog
post that actually discusses why
experimentation that skills more
successful
last thing is that holdouts should be
automatic
I'm just gonna give like a just an
example of how we make experimentation
accessible and intuitive like a
dashboard this is what a scorecard looks
like on statsig
um we have here a list of metrics um
coming down here in rows and we
essentially do the statistical
significance computation where if a
result if the lift is positive and
significant we color it green if it's
negative and significant we color it red
and if it's statistically insignificant
or not significant it's in Gray this is
very easy to understand but DS in
particular want to access the details
they want to be able to Deep dive into
the nuances of data and to do this we
actually
allow access to that back one
um if you hover over any metric we
actually show you the breakdowns for
test and control then there's this
magical view details button which shows
you a lot more
um and there's a whole bunch of stats
underneath here this one's my favorite
chart it's called day since first
exposure actually tells you the
experimental impact of a user when
they're first in the experiment they're
day Zero and how that Trends over time
and so therefore you can understand
whether it's a novelty effect or whether
you can expect this effect to last for
months
talk a little bit about some of the
lessons we've learned that or at least
on statsig and our ability to scale we
talk a lot about speed and execution
these are values we preach to our
customers and what you're buying but
it's also values we live by so we have
gotten to our scale by building quickly
and getting quick feedback and tests
done uh feedback you say that's where
the customer focus part
um this is where if um we it helps us
build empathy really understand what our
users are facing we do something called
customer Delights which is our ability
to take the feedback bug reports very
seriously and build these features or be
able to build features and fix problems
within the span of days if not even
hours what this does as for an early
stage startup is it really gets our
customers to trust us and really gives
them the belief that we can execute on
our long-term vision
I'll give a call out for like two sort
of like analytics functions and how we
use them for data science having thought
leadership being able to get out there
talk about experimentation as
experienced practitioners this is
something that our customers value a lot
it's also great for awareness and having
discussions with the community
um and the last thing is at the pace
that we've grown it's fair to say that
at any point in time our in data
engineering infrastructure will not last
six months so being able to like redo
all of that being able to build good
infrastructure good scalability has been
really critical uh for our success
my last slide
um I've I love talking about
experimentation so please feel free to
reach out I've got some ways to reach me
although that one looks like cut off
um but like yeah I'm also available
after this uh finally thank you for
attending my talk
thank you